so we talked a couple weeks ago about
the bad idea that is Michael Bloomberg
running for president Michael Bloomberg
is a billionaire longtime Republican
turned Democrat he owns the Bloomberg TV
channel the Bloomberg news organization
and he is way way richer than Trump we
don't know exactly how Trump rich is we
assume he's exaggerating but if Trump is
a billionaire Bloomberg is like a turbo
billionaire with a net worth reportedly
of more than 54 billion US dollars we
told you a couple weeks ago Bloomberg
was thinking about running for president
he now is running for president as a
Democrat in the Democratic primary now
according to the latest morning consult
poll Bloomberg is already polling 2% in
an average of recent polls Bloomberg is
already polling ahead of Tom Styer Amy
Klobuchar Cory Booker who Leon Castro
and has tied Tulsi Gabbard after just a
few days in the race that being said
Bloomberg obviously can't win the
primary he's not going to win the
primary there's no chance so what's
going on here I believe that Michael
Bloomberg is basically trying to prevent
Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders from
becoming the Democratic nominees whose
policies would directly affect Michael
Bloomberg potentially to the tune of
billions of dollars I'll explain
Bloomberg has said defeating Donald
Trump is the most important thing that
that's the priority that's what made him
consider running he believes Trump must
be removed and Tom Styer another
billionaire who's running has said that
exact same thing now steyr has a
fraction of the money Bloomberg has died
reportedly worth around a billion and a
half again as I said before Bloomberg
worth about fifty four billion dollars
and I said about Tom stires a candidacy
last week after the democratic debate if
you really want to defeat Trump don't
run yourself you have no shot put the
fifty million dollars or however much
Tom Steyer says he's willing to spend on
his campaign put that money into
defeating Trump by helping somebody else
put the money into voter registration
and into fighting voter suppression put
it into a huge TV campaign
to antagonize Trump and support the
eventual Democratic nominee if Tom Styer
is willing to spend 50 million to defeat
Trump is the point there are far better
and more effective ways to do it than by
running himself fine
Bloomberg has nearly 50 times the money
of Tom Styer if Bloomberg wants to hurt
Trump by Fox News and stop the pro Trump
propaganda I've mentioned this before
I'm not literally saying buying Fox News
I don't think it's for sale but the the
point is there are ways that Bloomberg
can take whatever amount of money he's
willing to spend on his campaign maybe
it's a billion of his own money who
knows spend it in other ways that will
actually help get rid of Donald Trump
because Bloomberg's not going to win and
that's where we get to the Bernie Warren
element of this if you go to Elizabeth
Warren's wealth tax calculator and you
put in Michael Bloomberg's net worth
Michael Bloomberg would pay 3.1 billion
dollars under Elizabeth Warren's wealth
tax so forget about the 50 million that
Tom Styer is spending even if Michael
Bloomberg spent a billion dollars it
could prevent Warren from winning and
save him an additional two billion
dollars in theory anyway now of course
let's be realistic the wealth tax is not
hugely likely to be made law even if
Elizabeth Warren is president I know
that this is sort of taboo to talk about
on on some slices among some circles on
the left but a lot of the policies that
Bernie and Warren's say they want will
never be made law this is just a reality
this is the way that it works you sort
of say what it what it is that you would
like to do and then you end up having to
negotiate on almost all of those issues
merely to a fraction of that so it's
very likely that Warren's wealth tax
would not be made the law anyway but
there is no question that the policy
ideas of Warren and Bernie are a threat
to Michael Bloomberg's personal finances
and increasingly it seems that
Bloomberg's goal is run to prevent
Warren or Bernie from winning the
primary and likely to keep Joe Biden in
the lead now this is logical behavior in
a
if your Michael Bloomberg from a
personal point of view it does make
sense there's a practical reality though
that I think Bloomberg may be ignoring
which is any support Bloomberg can pull
from the Democratic primary electorate
is more likely to come from Joe Biden
and other centrist candidates than from
Bernie it's hard to imagine too many
Bernie voters saying oh Michael
Bloomberg's running I'm gonna switch my
vote from Bernie to Bloomberg similarly
with Elizabeth Warren it's hard to
imagine that so I think it's a bad plan
I don't think the numbers actually
support the idea that Bloomberg can
prevent Bernie or Warren from taking the
nomination unless he's actually going to
proactively go out and spend money on
smearing them which we've not seen yet
but maybe we'll start but I think it
could just muddle things enough that it
still could prevent someone like Bernie
Sanders or Warren from taking a solid
lead in the National Democratic primary
which so far with the exception of
Elizabeth Warren for a few days a month
ago they have been unable to do it's a
calculation that Michael Bloomberg is
doing I think it's the wrong calculation
I think it's a calculation that's bad
for the country but this is what I
believe is going on let me know what you
think I want to hear from you what do
you believe underlies this Bloomberg
candidacy because he's not going to win
is it trying to keep Warren or Bernie
from being the nominee is it as some
people have emailed me merely a nearly
80 year-old Bloomberg who sees this as
the best opportunity to make a bigger
name for himself he has a lot of money
but maybe not as well-known of a
celebrity rich dude as you would like to
be is it merely that is it something
else I want to hear from you let me know
either by leaving a comment on this
YouTube channel a video if you're
watching on the YouTube channel or by
sending me a tweet at D Pakman what is
Michael Bloomberg really up to deep down
here